it's obviously at the moment of victory
a load of people decided that victory
wasn't enough I think there are though I
mean that we should credit it there are
a lot of young people in their teens and
twenties who who have actually absorbed
this worldview who do actually believe
that we live in a uniquely you know
dangerous time as opposed to being the
most fortunate people in history ever
anywhere and who actually have imbibed
these these ideas that you know we live
in this on the verge of fascism sort of
state and you have very little context
with history and all sorts of thing and
I I really one of the one of the aims of
this book is it it's written for those
people and I really hope they read it to
try to get them out of that and just
suggest a more reasonable view of the
situation we're in you know because my
experience in recent years I think I say
this in the introduction is that on all
of these issues of LGBT issues race
issues and women's issues basically my
experience in recent years has been it's
been like watching a train finally
pulling in to its desired destination
only at the very moment of pulling into
the station to suddenly get a head of
steam and go shooting off down the
tracks and off the tracks and scattering
people in their wake and it's always
like at the moment of victory a load of
people decided that victory wasn't
enough mm-hmm we see that we see that
all over those I mean I think Sweden is
probably the best example of that where
they've had this great egalitarian
society where men and women are so
obviously equal and yet the social
justice warriors are now trying to
re-engineer society so that there'll be
as many women engineers but we know that
women just aren't as interested in that
that's not sexist it just right I mean
listen this stuff is dementing because
we're trying to run a set of programs
that can't be run simultaneously and are
not going to work and you know I mean we
can both wax eloquent about that about
the number of contradictions for
instance in these movements that's going
on at the moment and
the most striking one to me is is what I
described as the hardware software issue
where how do it take us there I think I
am I owe this or inside from
conversations with our mutual friend
Eric Weinstein but the the way I see it
is that every rights movement in the
late 20th century discovered that the
best way to get sympathy for your case
was to say that you had a hardware issue
so gay uh argues that argues against a
lifestyle choice by saying no born this
way move from lifestyle choice to Lady
Gaga and um you see I actually say I
mean I'm definitely chucked out of the
Church of gay for saying this but I
actually say and I wrote this before the
most recent study emerged in science
magazine it was the largest study of gay
men and women to have come out so far I
actually say what that study did
conclude which is that it's it's almost
certainly got a significant hardware
component but there's also a nurture
rearing issue that there there are lots
of things that are slightly Buc that the
the settled place that we fought or at
least a lot of gay rights campaigners
got to but it was understandable to do a
hardware rather than software because it
countered that you know that they're
sort of religious bigotry among others
that did you know lifestyle choice and
but the problem about this is other
movements learned from that the trans
movement in particular and in recent
years in super fast time has been trying
to say absolutely nothing to do with
software this is a hardware issue trans
people are born trans and as I say we
actually don't know very much about it
but here's here's a dementing thing if I
may make the point which is that um we
are pretending at the moment in our
societies that gay is Hardware trans is
hardware but being a woman is software
now that is dementing right so you can
pick your you can somehow pick your
gender which we know is a physical
reality but you can't pick your
sexuality which science has proven
there's at least a conversation
to have their right so chromosomes are
of no significance but how you feel is
the most important thing we're trying to
make hardware software and software
hardware and you know it doesn't say
there's no wonder the this this sort of
casualty list the feminists has kept
growing because there's a very noble
given between a roll call of of them in
a chapter in the book there is no wonder
that a group of feminists kept coming
across this tripwire because it's
incredibly insulting for a lot of women
to be told you know as Judith Butler and
others that had started off the sort of
theoretical stuff and others have picked
it up and weaponized it but you know
being a woman is a matter of
performativity you know and as I say you
you can't run these two programs
simultaneously but we've been trying and
I think that's one of the absolute basis
for a dementing manner so I want to do a
little more on trans at the end but
we'll go in order of the chapters that
you did but can you just explain I
thought it was really interesting that
you separated the gay and trans chapters
because you know it is LGBT and I always
tell people that me as the G in this
case I have no more insight into what a
trans person's life is like than a
straight male would or lesbian would or
anything else these are these are very
different things but we've lumped these
letters together but why did you
intentionally separate it for the
purposes of the book well I think they
are separate things and I say at one
point in the gauge apt you know that the
G's don't have very much in common at
all with the ELLs I may never meet
particularly so no spaces no G's and
ELLs don't don't really have much in
common
the G's and the ELLs are very suspicious
of the bees and the bees and the bees
don't have anything really in common
with the t's and and they're all stuck
in this you know dave chappelle rather
just a week before my book came out did
this at a rather large audience on his
Netflix show you know that so in the
same car but they're very different
destinations and the thing with the the
thing with a t1 that is so interesting
which I know the same I really been
delving into this is speaking to a lot
of people and interviewing people and
you know really trying to work out as I
say what's actually going on here and
and one of the things I think that's
most striking about it and why
I finish on trans is that it's obvious
why trans runs against women I mean
sorry I should take by the way I should
say the fascinating thing about this is
of course the intersection lists and
social justice warriors all pretend that
these are like interlocking oppressions
and that if you if you undo one you will
undo the others or you know that you'll
create this sort of harmony because
women's issues and gay issues and racial
issues are all the same thing now now
the point I'm trying to make here is
that they are exactly wrong because each
of these issues actually runs against
the others so as I say it's obvious
whitey runs against women because it
among other things it does things and
makes claims about what women are that
are highly insulting to a lot of women
not all but an awful lot and then you
have the run against gay that trans
presents and I just I think this is I
think this is an absolutely fascinating
corner that hasn't been gone into enough
which is that you know as we know now
from studies young people diagnosed with
so-called gender dysphoria the stunt
what studies we have show that around
eighty to eighty-five percent of the of
the kids diagnosed with that are going
to grow out of it and are likely to
become gay men or gay women and we all
know this from our own experience and I
think that there has been a totally
submerged conversation in recent years
which has only happened in private and
wonder by the way one of the nicest
things about this book starting to be
read is the number of people who say to
me Douglas this is the conversation my
wife and I have over dinner and we say
we cannot talk about this outside of
this house and so on so I say my
self-appointed role is to say aloud all
of the things that everyone else
whispers but but I I know that this
conversation had been going on in among
gay people in particular which is am I
totally short that my you know sort of
tomboy friend
wouldn't have been diagnosed as actually
gender dysphoria am i sure that my you
know male friend who is a kind of camp
you know teenager wouldn't an if it had
been now have been told actually you're
not gonna grow up to be a happy healthy
gay man you're gonna grow up to be a
woman and we've decided your I see a
woman and that is that is that is that
hits are the absolute root of a lot of
gay men and a lot of gay women and we've
just passed it over as if it's all part
of the same happy rainbow coalition it
isn't it totally destroys the other bits
of the coalition so all right so let's
let's just continue with the trans part
then since we're in the thick of it
right now do you think there's also
something bizarre about the amount of
energy that the topic trans has where so
gay rights you know you can very easily
start you know you can go from Stonewall
you can look over the course of a few
decades where there were some wins then
it happened in America at least through
states rights and then eventually the
Supreme Court and a cultural awareness
and all that and then it was almost as
if the second gay marriage happened
everyone was kind of like this and then
trans which wasn't really being talked
about and you can argue maybe we should
have paid more attention to it
culturally or whatever but that it
suddenly became like v8 thing and the
second it became the iya thing you
couldn't take any counter argument
whatsoever yeah
Time magazine puts it on the cover in
2015 trans the next the next rights
battle see again there are people for
whom life is given meaning by having an
endless set of rights battles and once
you've done gay you got to do trans and
once you done trans you got to get onto
non-binary or whatever you've made up
today and so on and and I think that
this is people should be intensely
suspicious about people who's seen who
try to get meaning in their lives from
this some George in retirement issue if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell